in a bipartisan vote saturday night the
nevada assembly passed ab3
the police reform bill it limits the use
of chokeholds and requires more
intervention and reporting
when it comes to use of force incidents
while some believe it's a good step in
the right direction
others say it's either too restrictive
or it's not good enough
there are 38 eyes for nays nevada
legislators prioritizing police reform
ab3 effectively bans officers from using
chokeholds although lawmakers clarified
there are exceptions for self-defense
i don't want to give the impression that
a chokehold could never be used
other key parts of the bill include
requiring an officer to intervene if
another officer uses unjustified
physical force and requiring that action
to be reported
mandating drug and alcohol testing on
officers who are involved in shootings
and allowing the public to record law
enforcement activity
assembly bill 3 in front of you is the
embodiment of what we can do better
in the state of nevada because if we
aren't moving forward
we're standing still which means we're
falling
behind metro police in support of the
bill as an agency
we're always looking to improve our
policy and
and do what's best practices across the
country
others in law enforcement in opposition
why is it that suspects
that die in police custody always end up
on the ground prior to their death
the answer is simple they resisted
arrest some criminal justice advocates
saying the bill only covers the bare
minimum
i could be for this bill but
unfortunately it is not strong enough
ab3 was discussed in the senate as well
but some had problems with the process
it takes a long time to really get a
good bill worked out
this has been rushed the bill passed
through the senate committee of the
whole and will now go to the full senate
for a vote
reporting in the newsroom orco mana 8
news now